andrew bittner
alice
thanks for coming on the show again it's
great to be here again
round two baby
something special came out in round one
it's been growing yes
we'll have uh
round one linked in the bio highly
recommend watching our first
conversation
covered guaranteed clean energy
and we covered the birthing
of what is now the home dao is now the
home dao
yep
and now is the launch of the home dao
podcast we have
this is the inaugural
yes home dao podcast coming to you live
from
home dao and my home
yep
yep
and it's a launch also of
the ecosystem really at the same time as
it's the launch of the podcast which is
so exciting
yeah this has been something we've been
building now for five or six years and
now to be able to
share with everyone
the seeds that have been planted
to now see them as solid trees
and be able to now jump into the
ecosystem of web 3
and share our ecosystem and how we think
we can make a massive world difference
is uh
it gets your heart pumping with a little
bit of joy when you start to connect all
the dots
yep
and so
this will be nice
to
share the message and the vision of home
dao
especially using the visuals that we
have created and distilled for
this podcast as well as for just in
general branding and trying to distill
down what the core
mechanism is
of how this is going to enrich the
planet yes
and
[Music]
it's great that we get to both share
this with the home dao podcast audience
as well as with the simulation podcast
audience to cross-pollinate
also
so for those of you that are watching on
simulation i highly recommend checking
out all the links in the bio to home dao
getting involved in the discord and the
community if it resonates
and subscribing to the youtube channel
we'll have all these action items
including an epic nft drop multiple even
um
and
um
so sometimes i will be hosting the home
dial podcast which is really cool
in an honor
yeah and sometimes i'll be hosting it
yep
sometimes we'll have guest hosts
sometimes we'll have
one of our founders jonathan huber
jump on and hosting
this is a community podcast it's a
community project so you're going to see
a lot of different phases
yes perfect
um
i actually have a nice bio of andy that
i would like to share with you guys so
that you can get a better idea of really
his heart
um
and
so that you can get where he's coming
from
so
andrew bittner
has been recognized nationally in the us
for his work in streamlining
sustainability efforts
he's the ceo of guaranteed clean energy
which was recognized as the top clean
tech startup in the usa in 2021
for building a fintech platform that
streamlines energy assets by making it
financially viable for cities and school
districts to be sustainable in clean
energy
most recently he founded homedow along
with jonathan
which unifies the best people ideas
systems and funding in sustainability
bringing real world assets to web3
and again all the links can be found in
the bio including this bio
that we just read
so we'll be talking about next-gen
community in this episode which is
really at the heart of what the home
dial is
um
i'm finding it important now that we've
known each other for about a year and a
half
and have been creating together
to
also
share a brief recap also of like
guaranteed clean energy yeah
um i've been here with andy um
at his home for about 10 days now on a
what we call a heart sprint
and it's been incredible how many
calls
that he's been on with
school districts
and
really just serving them as they desire
to transition to clean energy
infrastructures
and guaranteed clean
energy has formulated a powerful
mechanism as
energy advisors where they can help the
school district
find the money
for the transition to clean energy and
so it becomes a win-win-win for the
people planet and profit
and the school district and the kids
especially are so happy in their
libraries and gyms and classrooms with
the new gen tech
it's amazing to be able to
share the behind the scenes
vision of what we really actually get to
do for communities because
as you were there in the office over the
last week and and you got to see the
calls
of communities saying you know hey we
want to do this we need help
and then listing off all the different
items that they need in their
communities for upgrades
whether it be led lighting insulation
windows roofs
solar
or any of the above it's so fun to have
somebody else see after the meeting
when
our office goes oh yeah we're going to
be able to get incentives for that
school district and put
10 20 million dollars of infrastructure
into that community
yo it's old hat for us because we do it
every day but what's what isn't old hat
is when we finish those projects and
leave those communities and see the look
on everybody's faces where they really
got a chance to
share their vision
and then
see it built out
from
an advisor
role
where we helped them build it so they
actually are a part of the process yes
it's not a bunch of contractors coming
in and then you know when it's done
they're they're looking around going
well what what did they do
it's so neat to be able to
just
leave a community where they went i
can't believe how much we were able to
do
in six months in one year we did
20 years worth of work
and i think that that's probably the
most rewarding part of the entire
process and why we got addicted to
serving communities
in the first place and then what they
taught us
has been completely transformative and i
think that that has been part of
the
the molding from guaranteed clean energy
as an advisory role
to now when i was approached to be part
of the home dow on the development side
of of how to listen to communities i
said well i've been doing it every day
for a decade
uh
the biggest thing is really just to
listen
and so let's build out a platform for
communities to be able to talk and
people to be able to listen but then
also
uh to be able to build an ecosystem of
developers
of individuals of activists
the whole nine yards and build it from
the inside out
and i think that's probably what i'm
most excited about in the web 3 space
is that as a private entrepreneur
everything is always build it from the
top down and how do you scale it how do
you sell software how do you
extract the maximum amount of margin
and
this is totally different it's
completely inverting the pyramid
it is saying
let's build this thing as wide and for
everybody as possible and let's have so
much value on the base
that everybody
can participate
and it'll actually get bigger as well
too
and i think that that's the crazy part
is that you're going to start with a
base of tens of thousands of people and
instead of that flow
going towards one or two at the top it's
going to start with 10 or 12 000 and
then move to 10 or 12 million and then
expand out that way so this inside out
growth that we're
experiencing in web 3 is just boggling
my mind
as somebody who's been in the space
and i'm so excited to be able to partner
up with so many epic people that
are just
begging to talk to somebody
and also
great people that are willing to work
together
to
build out communities from the inside
out as well too so it is just one of the
most exciting times i've ever
experienced in my entire life
it's really relatable to just
envision yourself walking into
school
and
the feeling of having next-gen energy
assets powering the school
for yourself when you were a kid as well
as for your kids and their grandkids etc
and
then now leveraging this bursting
ecosystem of web 3 to really
um and all these partners i'm so excited
to
unpack home dao in more detail well and
it's always been at a cost you know
walking through or doing big
construction has always been sacrifice
over here to gain over here
and the incredible thing about the
abundant nature of sustainability
is that it is a win from day one
it is a win from day one
and it is a win from day one uh and i
mean that that it impacts the people
better
the planet is better off and
the cash flow is better off and so
you're walking into these brand new
school buildings
and you're also going oh yeah by the way
the utility bills are smaller yeah it
didn't cost the school district any
money out of their own pocket so cool
just make pause
such an important highly overlooked
point
um school district no money out of
pocket and utility bills are lower
what
yeah and the places squeaky clean brand
new yeah
and you get to share with the community
the tremendous impact on the planet and
teach that
in curriculum with the kids yes
and all of the other impacts that happen
alongside of that and it's not just
energy i mean we're talking about really
holistic changes
uh getting into food getting into water
transforming the way that education can
function these are all part of the
things that we're addressing right now
in school districts but
ultimately homedow came to me and said
hey we want to do these things and i
said well i think we can do four or five
of them because we do them every day
and so we can help
but at the end of the day that's it's
this helping mentality of we'll raise
our hand and do what we can and and so
many other people are raising their
hands about what they love to do
and i think that's one of the other
things that's happening in this web 3
space with home dao is that so many
people are doing passion projects rather
than
checking into a job
and hitting the clock from nine to five
i mean the people that we've talked to
just in the last week there's not a
single
punch the clock person
and everyone's leading with their heart
and living in this this passion-filled
world and
we did
this week
and and this is ever since home dao has
happened but week after week after week
we're doing two or three months worth of
progress
uh in the traditional space simply
because the type of people
that are in the web3 space right now
it is
so fun to work with such selfless people
that are working in service to others
beautiful
i would love to launch into the first
visual yeah and then tell the story from
that it's a good segue
it's very easy to
talk about all the flowery things that
we're talking about
um
because it's
something that just as soon as you start
talking about it your heart just doesn't
want to stop talking about
sustainability or being part of it
but realistically
one of the things that
excited me and why i wanted to be part
of the home dao was that
it was way more than an idea
and i think that that was
one of the deciding factors for me which
was this is
not just a
concept this is a platform ready as an
ecosystem where we can come in and help
there are so many other people
that are already here and to be able to
be part of a 200 million dollar pipeline
of sustainable projects when you walk in
the door
is pretty exciting as somebody who's in
the space
uh
and i think that that's probably the
biggest thing that sets home dao apart
uh amen
it's the people but i mean a lot we're
talking to other dolls now and
the other dolls have amazing ideas and
they're going to be able to roll those
ideas hopefully into home dao or we're
going to help within their project
uh and build things out but i think the
biggest difference
as people really start to look
underneath the hood on on home dao now
that it's out in the public
uh
i think they're gonna go whoa
200 million dollars in projects and you
already have streamlined some of the
largest developers in the in the united
states that have already said i'm in
i can't wait to help
what can i do
you're starting off at eighty percent
done in this project from the gate and
then
sitting back and and now
making sure that the community
experience
uh of who this dow is really for
which is for the everyday
person
the everyday person not just in the
united states though that everyday
person in
uh in europe in
asia africa
in australia
this is for the people of the planet to
be able to take back the ownership of
these
uh sustainable assets and that also i
mean it's just
how can you not be part of the home dial
when that's what the mission was and so
i i had to be a part of this uh once i
found out what it was really all about
yeah
the most important part of that visual
is that bursting pipeline of projects
that is already there in comparison to
where so many other dows or
entrepreneurial endeavors start off
which is usually just at the seed of the
idea
but then the second core component of
that is the partners section which is
that green section that you were also
talking about which are the developers
yes and it's so beautiful because these
engineering procurement construction
folk
are
the ones around the us and around the
world that have already
learned the processes about next-gen
energy assets and how to implement them
in the areas and then there's an
inclusive stakeholding model with the
home dao that makes it a no-brainer for
them to get involved in this pipeline
yes
and it just creates a powerful ecosystem
that's unprecedented i want to ask you a
question about the um the pipeline of
projects yes so
how
how do how does the pipeline of projects
get actualized so there's
200 million plus in the pipeline of
projects so we're talking already let's
say schools and municipalities that are
ready to come on board for next-gen
energy assets yes
so what is needed
i think the easiest way to describe it
is to describe what's done in the
traditional world
and then now what's possible with web 3
and where it's headed which is also why
i couldn't say no to the home dao
in the traditional world when we have
a large-scale project
that would be
freeing a community
through energy independence and
producing food on site and all these
different things
in one perspective
it's so exciting for that community the
their costs are going to be way lower
they're going to be resilient they're
going to be able to
uh have
all of those assets on site so in the
worst case scenario they're still going
to have power and food and communication
in education
and still be able to function through
their community
which is unbelievably powerful and i
think we're seeing with
uh what's happening geopolitically how
useful that can be
as we sit here in a war time
but
what happens unfortunately in the
traditional world is we package up those
multi-million dollar projects and sell
those back to banks
and we sell those back to utility
companies
and so we want to avoid
the 200 million pipeline funnel to be
centralized again through banks and the
old ways
right that and i think that that's what
really touches a lot of people's hearts
in this is that that traditional way
as much as you're helping decentralize
things at a level
it then still gets centralized and so
being able to then
step into and transcend that model as
you step into the web 3 space
now you're talking about the ownership
of uh and being part of the community in
these projects
being individual people
not being giant corporations not being
uh the banks or the utility companies
and although they've been tremendous in
helping build some of the infrastructure
and get us to the place that we are i
look at those institutions sometimes the
same way i look at coal
coal was amazing industrial revolution
thank you thank you transcend time
absolutely amazing for a very short
period of time until we realized that
there was a more efficient and effective
way
renewables
across the planet now are almost 50
percent less expensive to build than a
coal power plant
and
it's clean energy versus coal energy uh
so it's just a complete no-brainer that
for me personally
is the same thing about web3 and being
able to decentralize
uh the
the ownership and community aspects of
these models so that you can
decentralize the community from its
freedom and sustainability side and then
also
have inclusive stakeholders in that
community that can also be part of that
project
uh and spread that out amongst many many
many individuals
which is just amazing so then the
pipeline of projects is in a sense
being saved
for
the proper
tokenomics
for it to then be deployed with correct
okay yes the amount of projects that we
have is consistently growing because
right now
uh we're not putting any of those
projects to work in the old model
uh and ramping up this unbelievable
amount of energy that is potential
energy uh to be able to just come in and
possibly become
i mean home down realistically from the
lens that i get to see it at
uh
it could become the largest utility
company in the world
and not be a utility company and i think
that's one of the most exciting things
that that i see but we also
are looking at objectively as engineers
and as financial people and as the ceo
of a traditional company i'm going
there's just nothing
like like this that i've ever seen in
the traditional space
that can exponentially grow this fast
but it makes sense
in the traditional world you make money
based on the amount of value you deliver
to the marketplace
there are a few
outliers
that do things differently in that space
but for
most people that start businesses and
most entrepreneurs
they
they are rewarded for providing value to
the marketplace
and
when you get to transcend it
and transcend
all of the old systems and step into
taos with decentralized autonomous
organizations
split that up
split up the ownership to everyone
and then simultaneously be able to serve
the world
the value to the marketplace is just
unbelievable and so
i think that that's exciting and i think
for us
the cool part is it's not it as much as
we love bitcoin
i've been around it for a very long time
this is not a project that is
selling a token for
hopium
in the
in the web 3 industry right this is a
project that says let's bridge the gap
between
pure
speculation on what uh
a system could look like and let's just
bridge it to real projects in real
communities that are delivering real
value
and
again that was just this overarching
thing of all of the the developers
across the country that are now working
together through home dao we all just
look at each other and go how do you not
be part of this
how do you sit down for an hour learn
about this and not
be part of what could be the greatest
thing that ever happens to humanity
uh
i
as we like to say
it's impossible to not be involved it's
impossible
yeah
beautiful
and
i would love to share the ecosystem
visual now
i think it's a great segue into that
so now you guys will get to see the
ecosystem visual
which i feel like does an incredible job
at distilling
such a
such complexity um
just down to
relatability
yeah
beautiful
and so i think it's also nice for you
guys
to
if you would like to you can visit
um
the homedow.com
and
you can actually see the visual there
on the website
and
you can zoom into it as you'd as you'd
like to there and
be able to read it more easily and
follow along uh more easily
so
we can
begin
with the we've conveniently numbered
um
we've created a
trail for you to follow with the numbers
in this loop
yes
so
we've started with
zero um in traditional format here of
of some of the deeper understandings
that we're all going to come back to and
start at zero
but
the main
starting point for
a community project is its community and
so
the home token itself is all community
oriented
it's
uh an opportunity for everyone to become
involved
we are going to have an nft launch
that is going to be the first
availability to
have access to those home tokens
but
more importantly you've got to see the
art
that is being created
we are working with a truly phenomenally
gifted
uh artist
and we're going to put some of her work
up on our twitter
and start sharing some of that
and so the artwork itself is so
connected to this mission uh we're gonna
be honoring uh 11 of the great people
in the history of humanity to get us to
the point of uh sustainability and so uh
that'll be fun and then i think there'll
be some some good arguments on our
discord about a lot of the people that
we left off like i can't believe we left
off buckminster fuller uh one of my
favorites i i lost the battle but this
is part of dallas this is part of voting
it's fun
but ultimately the community i think is
the big key
when it comes to starting this project
and the community is all about
being able to share that governance and
then be able to share
the impact on everything
i learned a long time ago when i did my
first project for a school
that doing a project and listening to
your client is totally different than
doing a project and getting done with
your project
because we used to do
specialized engineering and lighting
projects and sustainability projects for
fortune 500 companies and larger
entities and it was sterile you do your
work you do it fast you do it right
uh and then you get paid and you get out
of there and that's the end of it and
you go do it again
are not teaching you
they're not teaching you how they
want it to be they're teaching you the
most efficient and effective methods for
their facilities they want you in and
out and everything's proprietary
with a school district or a city
you come in and
you're building a project for them and
their community is telling you what they
want
and so there's this constant feedback
loop that is
9 10
11 12 13 opportunities in each project
of
feasibility this is what the community
wants feasibility this is what the
community wants this is how it works
from the financial side this is how it
works for the people this is how it
works for the planet and we learn so
many things
and that's what happens in the community
element
of the home dao
and so i'm
so stoked to be able to
just imagine
what ideas are going to come through our
community
and how many people are going to
or have had the best idea for 10 years
and haven't been able to do it because
they just haven't had a place that they
knew they could trust to bring good
ideas
and and know that it would go to the
world and not be
in a position where it was immediately
going to get swept under the rug or
bought by a large company and buried
all of that is completely a new
opportunity for the world to be able to
share something like this and be able to
take that idea and put it under the
blockchain so that it never leaves uh
it is never hidden is a really cool
concept
so
that's just one of the amazing elements
of community
we were also talking to
some people last night in california
that are developing new ways of
governance
through different nft ways of rewarding
participation
and some of the most innovative ways
that to me are simply
as close to being able to rewrite the us
constitution
uh as i've ever seen
uh and being able to liberate and free
people but also share opportunities for
governance and so
that's a huge part of community as well
that naturally out of this
sustainability mission
we're going to also
uncover some of the other most amazing
ways to serve communities
and so
we're talking a lot about community
because it's the most important one
we'll go through the other ones pretty
quick
i really like how you highlighted that
in all of the different areas of the
earth there will be a unique
creative
roaring of the community yes and that's
a very important part it's like what
does the grassroots
want in each area of earth yes because
it's going to be a color palette in each
one of those areas
and it's very important to offer the big
buffet
of clean
energy food water
internet education health care housing
and then
from that palette they can take cater it
cater it to yeah we're not dropping an
american buffet on africa
we are going to cater to what the
community wants
and that is how you develop
a real
impact like for just as a great example
uh we were talking today about
a high school that is actually very
interested in the agricultural
permacultural component
for teaching their kids and for having
food forest local
right there yes and so that
is very unique to that school yes right
to that community
and this is just an example of a unique
component that can then be applied to
what the community wants through this
dow mechanism and what the community
wants and we're going to design a
different
permaculture in
arkansas
than we are in michigan correct because
you have the climate zones you have so
many variables um
and let's let's hit the visual again
okay so um one more thing i'd like to
mention about the visual is that you'll
see that there are
the four in addition to the trail of
numbers that we've uh left
created
there are four primary components
starting with the treasury
the developers the projects and the next
gen assets
and then the loop and so
keep in mind those four primary
enlarged
components and then the
um
the number system that loops you around
great
so we started with home token zero at
the top
community shared account used to build
ecosystem discounts incentives strategic
alignments voting power the treasury
itself being funding community
governance yes
and so then what happens in the
application you have a million dollar
solar array for community partners
either a school a municipality hospital
thinking these large community impacts
and this strategic d5 funding so how
would this work yes so you know the home
token is there to be able to
talk about sustainability make sure we
get the feedback it's really that
utility
uh side of the
web 3 world that communities built on
and then you've got the other side
of the process which is
the actual building of the
infrastructures themselves
and so there's a separate token for that
we call it the u utility y-o-u
and that's because it's designed for the
individual person to be able to be part
of that process and so
that token will launch in the future
once we address all of the legal
standpoints that we need to address
but
right now the most important thing is
that we have a large enough community
that we can legitimize our govern
governance principles make sure we have
a large enough community to do voting
i do not want to be
the only voice
in these things i've seen how that goes
wrong in in so many other projects
unfortunately we already have a very
large development team
that that has that impact but then what
it really gets down to is let's build
some projects in some communities so
number one the the application and i i
think in this visual the best thing that
we did here is just say look let's
assume a million dollar solar array
being built for a community partner a
community partner a school district a a
city a hospital
just think
a large community that can receive a big
time
process here and we're using a solar
array because i think clean energy is a
great analogy for sustainability but
it's not just energy we are talking
about food we are talking about housing
we're talking about clean water
so many other different aspects of this
piece but again solar rays are a great
easy thing to
understand and so if you're going to
build a million dollar solar array
no different than purchasing a house
there is a down payment when you're
building infrastructure and so
one of the things we can do is tap into
the
treasury of those utility assets
to be able to
afford to get the project going and this
is one of the biggest issues right now
in the sustainability world is coming up
with that upfront capital to build
projects
the traditional world doesn't want to do
it they consider it
a higher risk type of scenario
because they don't understand it and
anyone who doesn't have an understanding
of things
something is going to feel as though
it's a higher risk
reality is different from
uh perception and so
the beautiful thing is that it's an
opportunity for
the dow to step in and be able to help
strategic partners like developers solve
their number one issue in funding
the other side to it is
defy is
unbelievable resource in this uh
transcended world of web 3 and crypto
and so
we can also leverage d5 platforms to be
able to
get
loans to do the back half of projects
which are
tremendously helpful and not having to
spend all your capital at first
because these assets
like a solar array produce revenue
and the revenue that they produce is
significantly larger than
the
loan payment on the seven hundred
thousand dollar
uh development cost that you're taking
the loan on so
on a million dollar project you may have
a loan for
fifty thousand dollars a year to pay
back principal but your revenue may be
sixty seventy eighty 90 000 a year
uh and so it's a no-brainer to
uh build these projects
and at the end of the day it
the developers don't want to be
a bank
and
a
a
funding company
and
all of these other things
they want to build sustainable projects
and engineers and construction people
are very good at engineering and
construction give them a holistic oh now
you have to be a bank and a credit union
and do all these other things and it
becomes very cumbersome and very
difficult to
take on that opportunity and manage
millions and millions and millions of
dollars and so that's what this
homedow ecosystem does is it allows
everyone to be
who they want to be
in sustainability if you're a fantastic
developer come on in
if you're an amazing electrician come on
in we need you
you know if you're a school district and
you want to go sustainable come on in we
want to build
sustainable assets for you and so
wherever you find yourself in this
in this uh world
uh there's a place for you in in home
doubt and so i think that's probably the
most exciting part for the developers
once they get underneath the hood and
have been looking at this
and before we continue on to developers
i really want to highlight the point
that has been made in this
um top right corner that we're in
with the application and the strategic
d5 funding
which is that
the primary question that's asked is
how
to pay for the one million dollar solar
array
this is the primary question right how
to pay for the next gen asset right
right this is the primary question and
you addressed it and i feel it's
important to just highlight it sure um
which is that the
loan
is 50 000 or so
dollars a month as just an example or a
year sorry a year
whatever it may be whatever it may be
but just to say that that's
then
able to be paid at the principal is able
to be paid at 60 70 80 90 000 a year
because instead of taking the energy
from the utility companies electricity
natural gas
water yes instead of taking that from
them now
it's
we have solar array or wind or chp
here yes at school or municipality
hospital etc
and
then
the money that's usually paid to the
utility
yes
is paid at which we'll get to at 10
less
than what it used to be to the dow
itself yes okay that's the core
part that then pays off so the the
questions usually that are roaring at
this part is where do you how what's the
how's the school come up with a million
dollars to build a project and and
that's what this solves
and that's one of the functions of this
dao is the dao is saying
we'll get the million dollars for you
and help you build this
and then we're going to help the
developer have that capital up front to
be able to start the construction and
buy the solar panels and fill out all of
the
forms and go through and a lot of people
don't realize you have to pay on a
million dollar project sometimes you
have to pay eighty to a hundred thousand
dollars
just to get the project paperwork
started to get it approved through code
uh and sometimes through those
centralized utility companies uh to make
sure that it's safe to go in that
community and there's a lot of good
reasons for those costs as well
environmental studies and other things
but they have to be done up front and
again that's a barrier that we wanted to
eliminate so that this process this
ecosystem
can be completely streamlined for the
community for the developer for the home
dow
and so that the people can then receive
those benefits because ultimately the
beautiful thing is that instead of the
school district
paying their utility bill every year for
that to that centralized utility company
and that money being gone
we're presenting a position where
that school district could literally pay
itself if they were
uh
token holders yes and that is
an unbelievable concept when you let
that sink in
uh and so that's where we we really
enjoy
come on in
come on in once you take it out of that
world and transcend it
you really start to see why
the world is going to change in such a
beautiful way and i think that's a lot
of of what the developers are perfect
experiencing now as well too because
if you're a sustainability developer out
there and you're hearing this
i want you to know
that you are going to receive
streamlined funding
with speed and certainty
and if that doesn't get you excited as a
developer
then you haven't been doing enough
business
[Laughter]
because that is what the the developers
need they need speed and certainty and
they need to be able to have that
streamlined funding process because
there's so many developers right now
that are have amazing projects but
because of the how slow the system is it
takes them a year and two months to go
through and time is money
time is money if we can get this done in
two months rather than a year and two
months that's a game changer
and that's another thing that the
homedow ecosystem does for developers so
that knowledge come on in it's so good
the best practice is
so good
cool
uh
and then when it comes to that
implementation
there are huge advantages then for
developers to not only have the utility
token side but to be part of the
community and so
uh home tokens and being able to have
that feedback on how to streamline
processes how to govern ourselves how to
build and where to put things
is a massive part of this
and uh you know i i think all the
developers are realizing they can join
what will be the largest non-utility
company in the world
uh by joining in as as part of the home
dell token and so so
it it naturally incentivizes everybody
in the ecosystem
for the best designs
products contractors
uh the installations to be the cleanest
and fastest and then overall
optimization and it just gets better and
better and better the more projects that
happen because it's all happening in a
sharing ecosystem versus a
proprietary patent everything
lock it in a box and don't tell anybody
what we're doing type of system
beautiful
love that
and out of that comes amazing projects
yes amazing amazing projects and so
that's where
again i think the home dow
that's what hooked me it was
this group of individuals is not
starting from scratch they are starting
with all of this potential energy of of
200 200 million in sign projects from
real communities
and cities and school districts across
the country
to be able to make a difference and the
key is though those community partners
will pay less they will have clean
energy
they will have sustainability pieces and
they will be that beacon
that embodies sustainability in that
community their kids at the school are
going to be learning about
sustainability because the solar panels
on the roof
they're going to be learning about
healthy food because the tomatoes are
right outside the door
you just can't miss it and that's a big
part of what's been missing you walk
into a school 10 years ago
and
it's a brick building with flickering
fluorescent lights
and
their boxes and
the
the grass may be mowed but that's about
it for permaculture
and uh
the world that will exist because of
what the home dow is doing and so many
other people in the ecosystem
are going to be able to bring
you're talking about community centers
being
utopias
is the closest thing i can think of it i
mean imagine 20 years from now
the utopia that would be if a school
district had all of its food produced on
site it had infrastructure for clean
water on site it had infrastructure for
clean
renewable energy on site
you're talking about game changer types
of opportunities and
that is what can happen today and i
think that's the other cool part it's
not crypto where it's like just
you know buy a magic internet money
token
and see what happens
uh buy this dog coin
this is saying
it's real
these are real projects
this is just leveraging the efficiency
of community and the efficiency of the
blockchain for
actual use cases
and that is the most powerful thing and
i think that's going to be the next big
movement in
uh the whole crypto sphere is use cases
yeah uh of these blockchains and we're
we we are going to be leading the charge
with one of the most exciting use cases
on the planet
sustainable assets
uh and so that's what really comes into
play here with these next gen assets and
as much as we are excited about bringing
on developers who have interesting ideas
there's also this idea of community
incubator
within the home token ecosystem and so
you're talking about people that
have an amazing idea having a place to
launch it and having mentors here in the
community to ask questions and grow and
build things i've been an entrepreneur
in the energy space for 12 years
you want access to me come to the home
dao discord i'm right there for you and
there's
20 other guys just like me
can't wait to help you yes uh and that's
what this is all about uh inventors
used to you know
have to hide all their stuff and trying
to not trusting the patent office and
not trusting that if they had some game
changer world innovation
they had nowhere that they really felt
like they could be trusted to bring it
to the world
talk about an innovation that is the
home dao as well so whether you're a
startup an innovator you're an activist
and you just want to go out and you want
to to
share the mission that this is the only
planet that we have there is no planet b
come to the home dao we need you too
you're an amazing marketer you're great
at web design this is a passion project
for you
come on over
we need you too this is a mission to
take all of the most beautiful things
that we can do and help launch it and
build it and bring it
you're an artist come on in
whatever you think you can give to this
ecosystem
we are willing to receive it and
i would imagine you're going to receive
it tenfold
uh from being able to to share the gift
as well
and so that's i i think
it's been my personal experience ever
since i got uh brought into the fold
here
and i can't you know
i feel like i'm already living heaven on
earth through this
uh i'm i'm living in the journey amen
we always talk about
you know human beings always just want
to get to the end and
i think i'm finally in that personal
place where i realize it is all about
the journey it's all about the adventure
and this is the most exciting adventure
yeah that i've yeah ever felt yes in my
entire life
and i want to share it with as many
people as we can because
it's a no-brainer right this is a
win-win-win for everybody for people
for the planet when the planet needs it
the most
and it is profitable so we can keep
spinning the wheel and keep doing it
over and over and over and over again
because it's all uh a beautiful
decentralized ecosystem that
you can spin the wheel the numbers guys
look at this thing and they go
oh my gosh
another way to say it is grow the pie
and increase the shares for everyone for
everyone yeah
for everyone
and you know one of the other things
that we're really excited about doing
within the community
is having the educational curriculum
so that when you're part of the home dow
we're also sharing
hey i came up with this amazing way to
grow beets in my backyard
hey i have this amazing innovation
that can help you get an extra 20 miles
per gallon on your uh car
whatever it may be
we've got
an area for these educational curriculum
and and also attracting some of the
greatest
uh minds of our time on this podcast
uh we've started
with a very low bar with me and we're
going to build to some brilliant minds
uh
in the future and i think that that's i
think also something that our community
can get behind in realizing how good of
an interviewer you are and bring on some
of the top uh minds in philosophy
uh in spirituality
in energy
uh in
quantum physics in
so many other
aspects of of the world and so i'm
really excited to see the people that
are going to be attracted to
the home now podcast and share their
ideas with the community in the world as
well because obviously our podcast is
going to be open to everybody to come
along and and be part of this
uh so
we are we've envisioned it like a magnet
the podcast is a big magnet for
attracting
these
greatest
people to get involved in the home doubt
and
it's just a perfect way to tell the
story yeah
and to be a magnet for the attractive
force into the vortex that is the home
dao into the taurus that is the home dao
yes it's so abundant
so this is a it's a great great
mechanism i love it
so
if anything is
come up in any of the listeners
minds today as we've been talking if
you've been thinking about anything
we've got a really easy access
to get involved on our website
it's got the links to the discord
discords the a really easy way to
communicate but good old-fashioned
contact us on the website works
come
take two seconds
send us your idea tell us about what you
want to do
come get involved
and you know at the end of the day
we're going to rely on the community and
and
that first way for people to really get
involved in a in a big way is through
the nft drop
and
if you follow our twitter and our
discord you're going to get to see a lot
of the
artwork that is coming out and you've
just got to experience this artist
her work is so
deeply
ingrained in love
and we've had several calls with the
artist and
uh
she and her team
are
some of the most giving loving people
that i've had a chance to experience and
only through zoom calls and they've
touched me in beautiful ways and so
the artwork and the nft drop is going to
be a great way to kick off
uh this to the public and get involved
in the project yeah and then from there
look out because
my goodness uh
we're gonna need so many people helping
because
it's going to grow
so fast and
that's the fun of it
this will no longer be
uh
50 people's project it's going to be the
world's project really really fast yeah
and we're just going to do our best to
make sure that there's as much love in
it as we can
what a powerful first episode
come on everybody
we can't wait to meet you we can't wait
to hear your ideas
it's for all of us
it is
the opportunity of a lifetime and
at the same time it is one of the most
crucial times in the history of humanity
to
take care of our planet
and simultaneously take care of of
ourselves
at the same time as we free
this planet and build generative
sustainable systems
we need to do that same thing for our
basic needs in life yeah
if there's one thing that i learned
through kovit it was
oh my gosh i am not prepared to take
care of myself i am completely reliant
on massive centralized systems to take
care of my family
and
um
what an eye opener
for somebody who's in the sustainability
world who thought he had it all covered
couldn't have been more wrong and so
i'm glad that i had that opportunity for
self-reflection during a really
challenging time and
now it's time to break out of that and
let's go celebrate it's about to be
spring
uh that's a big deal here in ohio where
our
our headquarters is right now so
the flowers are going to be popping out
about the same time as the community is
popping out with home dao so it will all
coincide in a beautiful way
so perfectly articulated
yeah
come on
come on
planet earth
come on
it's it's impossible to not be it's
impossible to not be involved
in the home now
perfect
perfect
all right everyone you know the drill
you can find all of the links in the bio
below
get involved
highly recommend checking out the home
dial youtube and subscribing there
and following on twitter
and
joining the discord if it feels relevant
also it's very powerful to share this
conversation
so if the video brought you value you
can like it that helps the algorithm but
it also helps to share the actual
conversation itself
with
friends family etc on social
because that
is a catalyst for other people to see
what's happening here and to get
involved
um one of the most powerful things you
can do is to share it also
and we love you so much thank you
everyone for tuning in
we hope that you feel what's
manifesting here
blossoming from the seed and how it can
really
serve our collective
yes
and
that's all
can't wait to meet you
thanks everyone